so now when we have written all this
code let's look at how to scale your
application using modules modules are a
serious heavy-duty function within app
engine and they allow you to partition
your code have better control of a
scalability and do version control and
online upgrades for simplicity we did
not use modules from building conference
central but it is something we strongly
suggest you start exploring on your own
by looking at the online documentation
alright let's get started when you
create an app engine application using
modules
it will conceptually be structured like
a tree at the very top we have the route
which is your application and your
application is made up of a number of
modules in this example to a module
grooves three concepts code related to
the module the instance class that
should be used to execute the code this
is the speed of the CPU and the amount
of memory that should be used the
scalability parameters including the
number of instances to start and their
lifecycle so a module groups code to be
executed the performers resources and a
scalability and instance lifecycle you
want to have each module can then have a
number of different versions associated
with it
a version is essentially a version of
your code being maintained in the module
so after you have deployed your
application into production you can
deploy new versions of your code and you
can have multiple versions running in
parallel and gradually migrate traffic
from the old version to the new this
capability allows you to diversion
upgrades without having to bring down
your application something that is
extremely difficult to do without that
engine and finally there are instances
an instance is what actually executes
the application code and if you want to
scale your application App Engine can
fire up more instances to manage the
additional load and since the instance
class and the number of instances define
the performance and scalability of a
module the capacity of your application
depends on the instance class and the
number of instances you run this is
configured on the module level and that
is exactly what we will look at now how
to configure a module so let's start by
looking at two scaling options for
modules manual scaling and automatic
scaling these specify the different
scale up scale down characteristic
of instances manual scaling allows you
to create instances that are always up
and running and that never terminates
because of this they don't have the
ten-minute execution limit when they
process tasks or con jobs since they are
always up and running they can work for
any amount of time and that means that
they are great to use if you have
long-running background tasks or cron
jobs the only thing you need to
configure for manual scaling is the
number of instances you want the module
to start
that's manual scaling let's now talk
about automatic scaling automatic
scaling is the option that allows App
Engine to automatically scale your
application up and down depending on the
load the first two options you can
specify for automatic scaling is the
minimum and maximum number of idle
instances you want what does this mean
why would you want to have idle
instances well instances have a start up
time and if you don't want your users to
wait for the response while your
application needs to scale up by
starting new instances and it could be
good to have idle instances available if
your application needs to scale up so
your users don't have to wait for more
instances to start let's now look at
latency where you can specify the
minimum and maximum pending latency
allowed for requests these parameters
work as follows so let's say a request
comes into your application right here
and there is no instance available to
process it then it is put in a wait
queue app engine now as a decision to
make when to scale up your application
using more instances well to begin with
it will wait for some time to see if any
of the existing instances become
available to process the request this is
called the minimum pending latency if
this time passes App Engine is
considering starting a new instance to
manage the requests and if the max
pending latency time expires then a new
instance will distort it for sure to
manage the load this is how App Engine
performs a scale-up of your application
rather than specifying a number for
these four parameters you can all set
them to automatic in such case App
Engine will set them according to a
dynamic analysis it performs finally
both manual and automatic scaling have a
common configuration element which is
the instance class the instance
class specifies the speed of the CPU and
the amount of memory to use for each of
the instances started check out the
developer documentation for more details
on the options available as you probably
see by now modules is heavy-duty stuff
and in addition to the scaling options
we looked at it also has versions that
we briefly touched on versions allow you
to perform online upgrades on part of
your system without any service
disruption without App Engine doing
automatic scaling and dynamic upgrades
are extremely difficult problems to
solve so make sure that you use this
great functionality